François Legault s'est adressé aux élus
municipaux aux assises annuels de l'UMQ
l'Union des municipalités du Québec le
premier ministre s'est présenté comme un
allié des municipalités rappelant qu'il
aura donné plus de moyens pour servir
les leurs citoyens mais les élus qui
souhaitent plus d'argent pour
l'adaptation au changement climatique
sont restés sur leur appétit François
Legault leur a dit qu'il n'existe plus
de marge de manœuvre à Québec il
n'existe pas plus de marge de manœuvre à
Québec que dans les municipalités
on partage l'assiette fiscale les
municipalités ont du foncier nous on a
beaucoup des impôts sur le revenu sont
dans le plafond on a les impôts sur le
revenu les plus élevés en Amérique du
Nord donc moi je veux bien 2 milliards
par année mais je voudrais juste que
quelqu'un me suggère ou prendre cet
argent
Martin dorfosse présidente de l'Union
des municipalités du Québec est avec
nous maire de Varennes nouveau président
de l'INQ bonsoir monsieur danfos
salut monsieur Fillon les assises donc
se déroulent la Gatineau où vous êtes en
ce moment vous venez d'être nommé à la
tête de l'UMP c'est quoi le dossier le
plus près ça en ce moment pour les
municipalités
en fait normalement le dossier le plus
pressant aurait été le renouvellement du
pacte fiscal et la négociation pour 2024
là vous aurez compris que dans les
dernières journées avec les inondations
qu'on a partout puis surtout on est à
Gatineau Gatineau malheureusement a subi
trois périodes d'inondation dans les 10
dernières années donc l'adaptation au
changement climatique a pris le haut du
pavé et honnêtement me suffit Léon on ne
parle que de ça mais on fait référence
au pacte vert qu'on a déposé en
septembre qui nécessite des
investissements importants parce que si
on investit pas aujourd'hui pour mieux
s'adapter ça va coûter 15 fois plus cher
pour réparer oui exactement c'est assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de constater
qu'un investissement aujourd'hui nous
permet d'économiser plus tard mais
investir aujourd'hui demande plus
d'argent pour les municipalités monsieur
Legault veut pas aller là le 2 milliards
il vous demande on va le chercher où
mais en fait c'est étonnant d'entendre
ça parce que entre la fermeture de son
discours du mois de septembre à
aujourd'hui il y a eu une évolution très
importante la première des choses il
reconnaît l'adaptation changement
climatique il reconnaît que des
changements du climat et il y a même
consacré des sommes additionnelles pour
nous permettre de mieux s'adapter par
contre quand il lance sa série de
chiffres dont un point 4 milliards et
d'autres la réalité c'est qu'il y a un
650 millions directement en lien avec
l'adaptation changement climatique mais
la particularité c'est que c'est pas
exclusif au milieu municipal l'ensemble
des entreprises du Québec ont accès à ce
fond là c'est déjà un bon pas dans la
bonne direction mais tout le monde
reconnaît qui en prend plus mais est-ce
qu'on taxe davantage les citoyens est-ce
qu'on augmente les impôts on va le
chercher où cet argent
honnêtement je pense pas qu'on doit
taxer davantage ou augmenter les impôts
peut-être pas les baisser mais ça c'est
un autre dossier mais je vous dirais que
c'est davantage d'un Choix
environnemental qu'on doit faire à
partir du moment où on est conscient que
les changements climatiques aura des
impacts énormes pour notre population
pour notre environnement mais c'est des
choix et celui-là selon l'Union des
municipalités avec un pacte vert fait
par Ouranos et WSP et ce sont des
scientifiques qui ont démontré
clairement qu'il faut faire des actions
concrètes aujourd'hui nous on pense que
ça devient une priorité le ministre des
Affaires municipales André Laforêt se
dit prête à négocier dès maintenant le
nouveau pacte fiscal pour 2025 à 2029
est-ce que vous avez déjà une rencontre
de prévu
en fait on a notre déjà eu puis soyons
francs c'est très agréable de discuter
avec la ministre la forêt elle a une
grande ouverture on a toutes sortes de
discussions mais soyons francs le pack
est encore valable jusqu'en 20 fin 2024
mais aujourd'hui on a déjà eu des
confirmations du Premier ministre entre
autres la progression du point de TVQ
qu'on veut intégrer dans une loi il l'a
reconfirmé ça s'en vient la
modernisation de la loi sur
l'expropriation il l'a confirmé aussi
qui ont eu dernièrement le droit de
préemption donc ce sont des gains
importants des demandes historiques on
progresse mais la relation avec Madame
la forêt est très bonne dégâts combien
au municipalités combien ça va rapporter
aux municipalités ces gains là ce point
supplémentaire notamment de tes vécus
en fait c'est intéressant parce que dans
le premier pacte j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts mais on parlait peut-être de 75 à
80 millions par année mais étant donné
que une inflation à ce point importante
que nous subissons le mini municipal il
y aura une progression fulgurante et
importante parce que le gouvernement
reçoit beaucoup de nouvelles sommes à
cause de l'inflation on en profitera
bien sûr à notre tour après 2024 est-ce
que des taxes est-ce que les taxes
municipales contenu que votre votre
enjeu sur le pacte fiscal est toujours
de trouver de nouvelles sources de
revenus là on travaille sur de nouvelles
sources de revenus mais en attendant
est-ce que les Québécois et les
Québécoises doivent s'attendre à des
hausses de taxes municipales notables
honnêtement il y a aucune ville qui
souhaite ça mais honnêtement monsieur
Fillon j'ai adoré j'ai adoré le
reportage précédent mon intervention sur
l'énergie puis quand on regarde
l'alliance des villes de l'est qui
produisent énormément d'énergie avec
l'éolien c'est une source de revenus
innovante et nouvelle qui est
extraordinaire on a le problème
d'énergie va pousser probablement un axe
ou l'ensemble des municipalités du
Québec avec l'union avec les villes où
on pourrait créer une nouvelle filière
et répondre aux besoins du Québec et aux
nouvelles sommes financières que les
vélos ont besoin monsieur d'enfance très
intéressant merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI